this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video we're
going to talk all about mitochondria
and their role in the aging process so
i'll begin by explaining the essential
biochemistry you need to know about
mitochondria
and then we'll look at the different
theories of the mitochondrial role in
aging
that will touch upon our understanding
of reactive oxygen species
and mitochondrial dna mutations in the
aging process
and then lastly we'll consider the
question of whether targeting the
mitochondria
could have therapeutic potential for
either health span or lifespan
so what's a mitochondria then well
mitochondria
are organelles found within your cells
and unlike the nucleus that's present
as one copy there are multiple copies of
mitochondria
within your cell so what do they do
well if you asked any biochemistry
students including myself
what is the function of mitochondria we
would instantly reply
the powerhouse of the cell but
mitochondria are not just important in
creating the energy source of the cell
which is provided by the production of
adenosine triphosphate atp but they also
play critical roles in cell death
oxidation of fatty acids and the
generation of iron sulfur clusters
so mitochondria are vital for cell
survival
but they're not just vital they're also
truly fascinating
and i know i find a lot of things
fascinating but i really mean it this
time
because mitochondria have their own dna
and whilst as you can see in this figure
here it's a bit small compared to the
entire size of the nuclear dna
mitochondrial dna contains the genetic
information
for 13 proteins and some of the rna
machinery that helps it to produce its
own proteins
and if you're wondering why mitochondria
has its own dna
it comes down to their evolution you see
initially
a long time ago there was an
endosymbiosis event
whereby a cell engulfed a bacterium
and over time changes occurs dna was
lost
and we've now got the mitochondria well
it's a bit more complicated than that
and it is still being investigated
anyway despite the fact that the
mitochondria has the genetic information
to produce 13 different proteins
mitochondria
actually contain more than a thousand
different proteins
so where are they coming from well it
turns out that the genes encoding these
proteins are found in the nucleus
and so the mitochondrial dna only
encodes for around one percent of its
proteome
and so this is direct evidence that
there's communication going on between
the nucleus and the mitochondria
and actually goes both ways with the
mitochondria also influencing the
nucleus
for example the different metabolites
and intermediates of the steps involved
in respiration
that occur in the mitochondria can also
modify epigenetic marks on chromatin
and so this includes acetylation and
methylation of histamine proteins
and also other factors such as
alpha-ketoglutarate
that can influence the activity of
enzymes that modify
the epigenetic marks on dna and
modification of epigenetic marks
can influence gene expression so there's
actually loads of communication going on
between the mitochondria
and the nucleus and this is really
important for a cell
and it enables these different functions
of the mitochondria to be carried out
so therefore unsurprisingly mutations in
mitochondrial dna
have been shown to cause a variety of
different diseases but it's a bit more
complicated than normal mutations in
nuclear
dna because with the mitochondria there
are hundreds of thousands of copies of
mitochondrial dna within one cell
and differing percentages of those cells
may actually have the mutation
whilst the others don't and so this
actually results in something referred
to as
heteroplasmy whereas heterogeneity
in the state of mitochondrial mutations
within just one cell
so what has all this got to do with the
aging process
well mitochondrial dysfunction is
included in one of the nine hallmarks of
aging
and there are three main theories to
support the link between mitochondrial
dysfunction and
aging the first one of these theories
was postulated
more than 40 years ago and that is the
free radical theory of aging
and so what this theory states is that
the mitochondrial dysfunction
that occurs with age results in
increased production of so-called
reactive oxygen species
that can cause further mitochondrial
damage and also damage in the rest of
the cell
and so it's thought that reactive oxygen
species will be harmful for the cell
if their levels exceed the capacity of
the cell to effectively neutralize
these reactive oxygen species and
eventually convert them through to water
via hydrogen peroxide as an intermediate
and so whilst at high levels reactive
oxygen species really could be
detrimental for a cell
that doesn't necessarily mean that in
the majority of cases
it's even a problem and so the
mitochondrial three radical theory of
aging
has been challenged more recently in
light of the evidence
showing that increased reactive oxygen
species
may prolong lifespan in yeast and worms
moreover genetic manipulations in mice
that increase mitochondrial reactive
oxygen species
don't actually accelerate aging in the
mice and this is because reactive oxygen
species
also play essential roles in cellular
signaling with the general idea being
that the presence of these reactive
oxygen species
promoting the up regulation of
anti-stress responses within a cell
so they can counteract any potential
problems and so because of this evidence
you might be feeling quite confused
right now
are reactive oxygen species good or bad
well this is the reason why in the
hallmarks of aging
mitochondrial dysfunction is regarded as
an antagonistic hallmark
and what that means is that it's one of
the hallmarks that seem to have
opposite effects depending on their
intensity so
at low levels they may mediate
beneficial effects
but at very high levels they can become
deleterious
in the case of reactive oxygen species
that's when they're too high
and overcome the cell's ability to
neutralize them before they cause
even more damage and subsequently
cellular death but the other reason why
reactive oxygen species
would thought to be causing further
mitochondrial dysfunction
was due to their ability to cause
mutations in mitochondrial dna
however more recent evidence seems to be
showing that
the increase seen in mitochondrial dna
mutations
that occur during aging don't seem to be
due to oxidative damage
instead the mutations that seem to arise
in mitochondrial dna during age
seem to occur by errors that occur
during replication
of mitochondrial dna and so this brings
us on to the second theory of
mitochondria
with aging which is increased
mitochondrial dna mutations
and the first lines of evidence
supporting mitochondrial dna mutations
with aging
comes from the fact that the levels of
mitochondrial dna deletions
increase of age in several tissues such
as the brain
retina skeletal muscle sperm ovaries
liver and heart tissue in addition it's
been shown that parkinson's disease
patients
carry high levels of mitochondrial dna
deletions in some dopamine neurons
but some of the strongest evidence so
far comes from studies on mice
that are deficient in mitochondrial dna
polymerase gamma
and so this is the enzyme that
replicates mitochondrial dna
and when it's mutated in these mice it
increases the number of errors that it
makes
and so more errors more mutations and
what's seen in these mutant mice is that
they exhibit
aspects of premature aging and reduce
lifespan
and that's in association with the
accumulation of random point mutations
and deletions in their mitochondrial dna
moreover cells taken from these mice
show impaired mitochondrial function
but interestingly this isn't accompanied
by increased reactive ocean species
in line with what i previously said
about the weaknesses in terms of the
free radical theory of mitochondria and
aging
but to really be certain that the
increased load of mitochondrial dna
mutations is promoting the aging process
would be to test genetic manipulations
that can decrease the amount of
mitochondrial dna mutations
and to see whether or not they can
extend lifespan so to do the opposite of
what they've done in these small studies
with mutations and dna polymerase gamma
and so that leaves the third theory
of mitochondria with aging which is
bioenergetic decline
and along with that that also includes
loss of mitochondrial integrity
and so as i mentioned earlier the
mitochondria isn't just
involved in making atp it's also really
important
in coordinating apoptosis a form of cell
death
and so loss of mitochondrial integrity
can also impact the response of cells to
different stresses
and it can also impact signaling with
the nucleus in terms of regulating
nuclear gene transcription
and also interactions with other
organelles and so the reduced efficiency
of mitochondrial bioenergetics
may come from a loss of the
mitochondrial integrity and dysfunction
of the complexes that helps it generates
energy but also due to reduced
biogenesis of mitochondria themselves
and interestingly biogenesis of
mitochondria is regulated in part by
pgc1 alpha and so pgc1 alpha is encoded
in the nucleus
and can mediate mitochondrial biogenesis
by regulating the activity of several
other transcription factors
notably nrf1 and nrf2 and also the
mitochondrial transcription factor a
but the most interesting thing is that
pgc1 alpha itself is regulated
by cert 1 and nad plus dependent teton
and speaking of nad plus a study came up
last year that shows that niacin
and nad plus precursor could help
improve muscle performance
in adult adult-onset mitochondrial
myopathy and so that's a disease
caused by mutations in mitochondrial dna
and so how much of this could have been
mediated
through cert-1 activation and
subsequently pgc1 alpha modulation
is not very clear especially because
there's acetoin that's found in the
mitochondria
cert iii which could also be impacted by
nad plus supplementation
but it's also interesting to note that a
clinical trial is currently in progress
at cambridge
that's investigating how nicotinamide
riboside
might be impacting mitochondrial
biogenesis and so nicotinamide riboside
is another nadplus
precursor that's previously been shown
to increase the transcription of genes
involved in aerobic respiration that
occurs in the mitochondria
and was shown to improve motor
performance of myopathic mice
and so this clinical study is trying to
investigate whether or not there's a
mechanistic link
between mitochondrial biogenesis and
physiological function in humans
with a similar mitochondrial disease in
a similar vein endurance training and
alternate day fasting
may also be able to improve health span
in part through their capacity to avoid
mitochondrial degeneration
and this again could be linked back to
activation of cert one
that is shown to be activated during
fasting but all of these different
interventions could be impacting
multiple different hallmarks of aging so
what about targeting the mitochondrial
dna
mutations themselves well interestingly
a study came out last year
that developed a base editor that could
enter the mitochondria and edit bases
within the mitochondrial dna
now this is very early basic research
work but does raise hope for treating
different mitochondrial disorders
but in addition to that it could be used
as a research tool to further understand
the implications of mitochondrial dna
mutations
and that in itself could be useful for
further underpinning
the association between mitochondrial
dna mutations
and the aging process and so all in all
there's clearly a lot of work still to
be done to understand
the association between mitochondria and
longevity
and that's in part due to the fact that
mitochondria may be small
but they're mighty and are involved in
so many processes within a cell
and dissecting its details will remain
to be a challenge
but with new molecular tools such as the
base editing tool i just mentioned
it's hopeful that in the future we will
begin to understand it better
and can use the information to see how
therapeutics can be developed
to prevent bioenergetic decline and
reduce the burden of mitochondrial dna
mutations
so with that i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this week's video longevity
technology
for which i am very grateful longevity
technology
deliver high quality daily news and
insights on research
investments and technologies that extend
health span and lifespan
find the link to their website in the
description so i hope you've learned
something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening